what are your
uh i mean you've talked with him but
just as a matter of personalities
because it's a beautiful story what are
your thoughts about eric weinstein's
work
you know i i think his his um i mean
he did a phd thesis in mathematical
physics mathematical physics
and and you know it's it it seems like
it's kind of
you know it's it's in that framework and
like i'm not sure how much further it's
got than his phd thesis
which was 20 years ago or something and
i think that you know
the the you know it's a fairly specific
piece of mathematical physics
that's quite nice and um what trajectory
do you hope it takes
i mean well i think in his particular
case i mean from what i understand which
is not
everything at all but you know i think i
know the rough tradition at least
is operating in is sort of theory of
gauge theories
gauge theories local gauge invariants
and so on okay we are
very close to understanding how local
gauge and variance works in our models
and it's very beautiful
and it's very um and you know
does some of the mathematical structure
that he's enthusiastic about
fit quite possibly yes so there might be
a possibility of trying to understand
how those things fit
how gauge theory fits very well i mean
the question is you know so there are a
couple of things one might try to get in
the world so for example
it's like can we get three dimensions of
space we haven't managed to get that yet
gage theory the standard model of
particle physics says
that it's su 3 cross su 2 cross u1
those are the designations of these um
lee groups
um it doesn't but but anyway so those
are those are sort of representations
of symmetries of the theory and um
so you know it is conceivable that it is
generically true okay so all those are
subgroups of a group called e8 which is
a
weird exceptional lead group okay
it is conceivable i don't know whether
it's the case that
that will be generic in these models
that it will be generic
that the gauge and variance of
the model has this property just as
things like general relativity which
corresponds to thing called general
covariance
which is another gauge-like invariance
it could
conceivably be the case that the kind of
local gauge and variance
that we see in particle physics is
somehow generic
and and that would be a you know the
thing that's that's really cool
i think you know sociologically although
this hasn't really hit
yet is that all of these different
things all these different things people
have been working on in these
in some cases quite abstruse areas of
mathematical physics
an awful lot of them seem to tie into
what we're doing and
you know it might not be that way yeah
absolutely that's a beautiful thing i
think i mean
but the reason i so the reason eric
weinstein is important
is to the point that you mentioned
before which is it's
strange that the theory of everything
is not at the core of uh
the passion the dream the focus the
funding
of the physics community it's too hard
it's too hard and people gave up i mean
basically what happened is
ancient greece people thought we're
nearly there you know the world is made
of platonic solids it's you know water
is a tetrahedron or something
we're almost there okay long period of
time where people
were like no we don't know how it works
you know time of newton
uh you know we're almost there
everything is gravitation
you know time of faraday and maxwell
we're almost there everything is fields
everything is the ether
you know then the whole time we're
making big progress though
oh yes absolutely but the fundamental
theory of physics
is almost a footnote because it's like
it's the machine code it's like we're
operating in the high-level languages
yeah um you know that's what we really
care about that's what's relevant for
our everyday physics we've talked about
different centuries in the 21st century
will be
uh everything is computation yes if that
takes us all the way we don't know
but it might take us pretty far yes
right that's right and
but i think the point is that it's like
you know if you're doing biology
you might say how can you not be really
interested in the origin of life and the
definition of life
well it's irrelevant you know you're
studying the properties of some virus
it doesn't matter you know where you
know you're operating at some much
higher level
and it's the same what's happening with
physics is
i was sort of surprised actually i was
sort of mapping out this history of of
people's efforts to understand the
fundamental theory of physics
and it's remarkable how little has been
done on this question
and it's you know because you know there
have been times when there's been bursts
of enthusiasm oh we're almost there
and and then it decays and and people
just say oh it's too hard but it's not
relevant anyway and i think that the um
the thing that um you know so so
the question of of you know one question
is why does anybody why should anybody
care
right why should anybody care what the
fundamental theory of physics is
i think it's intellectually interesting
but what will be the sort of
what will be the impact of this
you